kevin clark of the ringer back here on
the rich eisen show how are you kevin
i'm doing great a lot of sports to take
in rich no question that's that's why we
put it in a bracket you know
that's why we're going to put it in the
bracket the only way
so more than four things you got to
throw in the bracket i will give you the
floor on uh the tyson fury deontay
wilder fight uh that went down on
saturday night what were your thoughts
taking that one in kevin well i i
thought it was gonna go actually i i
might have been the only person who
thought he was gonna go that way uh
gianta wilder became vastly underrated
in the past 19 months rich i mean it's a
little bit like a football team where we
see them lose one game and we just sort
of get off the bandwagon wilder still
was the hardest puncher in the sport
tyson fury was talking about that going
into the the the third uh fight last
week he was saying guys deante wilhelder
still has the hardest right hand in
boxing um and so this was always on the
table that he was gonna change his game
plan a little bit um he was more
aggressive he only landed nine jabs but
he threw them he changed his game plan a
little bit that's what he had to do um
so fury's a better boxer if they fought
a hundred times fury you'd win the vast
majority of them um but i was not
surprised there were some knock downs
because when diaz waller gets in the
ring with a guy he knocks him down
that's how it normally happens and that
wilder knocked him down in two of the
three fights they've had they're not
going to have another fight i assume um
but we saw uh
boxing at its best basically and and uh
we saw what uh you know over the three
fights you guys have had we saw how uh
boxers can change the world can change
the sport can change um i i i loved it
and i i mean
when when
wilder knocked down fury
yeah i mean
i i i just can't i still can't get
enough of the constant that appears to
be with these fights is the num the
amount of seconds that fury gets to get
off the
canvas it happened again do you think
with these two fighters what do you
think that he got too many
too much time to get up what do you
think i mean i listen i there's so many
in heavyweight boxing in high level
heavyweight boxing rich there are so
many questions going back to
1920s about long counts right and i
think the guys get you saw that anthony
anthony joshua lost to andy ruiz in
their first fight
three junes ago um they
people were saying joshua was getting
you know 17 seconds in some cases to
actually re-engage um because he kept
getting knocked down he was the
heavyweight champion in the world um so
it's a gray area i mean i think there's
still people who argue rich in the first
fight that with the fact that tyson fury
basically his eyes were closed that that
should have been waved off and was a uh
you know was a knockout people have
argued that dante wilder has argued that
jack reese referee said it was the best
call in his career to let that go um so
it's always a bit of a gray area i
thought it was a long count uh but
that's just high-level heavyweight
boxing it's all
but rules are meant to be uh bended uh
bent in uh in heavyweight high-level
boxing afterwards fury said that he uh
told wilder essentially good fight and
wilder said i'm not gonna do anything
what uh respectful or uh
no sportsmanship that's what he said
right
what's up with that oh it's a good
lesson uh you know listen so i was in
the second fight it was the first fight
too but i was in the second fight where
wilder lost and
i went over to the tunnel to watch him
walk back in and he looked as defeated
as any athlete i've ever seen in my life
um and i've been in post
super bowl locker rooms after a team
lost um i've been in some pretty heavy
duty uh places as far as emotions go and
i've never seen somebody as upset as
wilder i think that wilder's ego was
tied into the fact that he had knocked
40 guys out and anybody he'd ever been
in the ring with he had knocked out even
if he didn't knock them out the first
time he would fight them again and knock
them out then um i've spent some time
with deontay wilder he's this swaggering
personality and i kind of think at age
35 he's not ready to consider himself
anything other than that guy than the
guy who knocks too plowed whenever he
gets in the ring with them and i think
he's having a tough time adjusting to
this reality and that is why i think
you've seen him act a little pouty not a
little pouty a lot pouty in the two in
the two losses he's had so where does
fury now stand in terms of all time one
of the greatest oh he's up there he's up
to always he's gonna i don't know i mean
usyk who who beat anthony joshua a
couple weeks ago now has the heavyweight
championships that fight still out there
i mean fury everybody's been talking
about what happens with dan when anthony
and joshua and tyson fury get in the
same ring uh they're both english
they're both hugely famous you can sell
out you know ninety thousand feet
stadium over there it's gonna be a route
i mean it is going to be a route tyson
ferry will destroy anthony joshua right
now if they fought unless joshua made
huge changes to his game which i don't
see coming um so he's up there with the
all-time greats he's going to dominate
this era of heavyweight you know he's
talked about wanting to retire after a
couple more fights he's only 33. i don't
see it but i also see that i just don't
i i see maybe only two heavyweights
capable of even giving him an
interesting fight so uh there's not a
lot for him out there he's really really
good he beat klitschko he beat wilder uh
he's gonna beat joshua he'll beat us
yeah he's dominating in this era well
what about the fact that nobody thought
that that another heavyweight era was
going to matter right i mean let's be
honest because this we're now in the
we're now in the era of ufc we're now in
the era of there's 50 million ways to
take things and i'm holding up my phone
right here you know and there's and
there's so many different ways for us to
not pay attention to something that we
we even get a sniff of the fact that is
irrelevant and then his own personal
journey i mean i retweeted a video of of
his honest soliloquy when he was here uh
two years ago about wanting to kill
himself
and he's how he still battles mental
health and how he is in this 21st
century you know uh a guy who looks like
he's straight out of a a guy richie
movie he was going to be you know you
know lock stock and two vinnie jones you
know
that he comes across and he talks about
mental health and he sings to fans after
he wins he serenades them
i i mean talk about it shot in the arm
and what he means to the sport it really
is incredible he's one of the all-time
greats you got to give it up you know
boxing boxing is always going to be
personality driven and it was funny
because they're not funny but uh
what my wife and i went to
the first fight as a fan quite frankly
um it was in la and i just bought a
ticket and to illustrate kind of the
journey i showed her the um the video
the the the when when when tyson was in
your uh studio and she was all in after
that because she understood the journey
and that's what boxing is about on the
other side wilder was going through all
this because he wanted to support his
daughter um he was a beer delivery guy
and he went into a a boxing gym and
thought he could fight and he could
and i think that at its best boxing
has the best stories because
it's just so real and raw and there's no
hiding that's i think part of the reason
wilder can't take losing is there's just
no hiding from it you can't blame it on
a coach you can't blame it on an
offensive line it's you and the other
guy um and i think that the heavyweight
division can matter if there's two three
good fights that everybody gets into i
think that it was really hard and listen
i was again i was at the first fight uh
just as a supporter of boxing in la and
it was not sold out between wilder and
fury i don't think a lot of people cared
when they had an epic match it built on
itself i went to the second one as a
journalist dicaprio was there mahomes
was there so mac was there it became a
huge huge thing i did not i did not see
mahomes in dicaprio with the first one
at the staples center okay but boxing
has a way of building on himself and
that's what you have to give these two
guys credit for is they they entertained
us so much they got us talking about
heavyweight boxing again when frankly i
i'm with you i thought it was going to
be boxing was going to be more
middleweights more featherweights more
welterweights uh heavyweight headway
boxing for right now is back
brockman and tj were at that first fight
i don't know if you if they you were you
not close to uh so we ran into we ran
into
the lobby yeah mr and mrs clark you ran
into them rotunda
famously brockman said you wanted to bet
on a draw and didn't do it and didn't do
it yep
that is i think i might have talked him
out of it that is by the way that is so
on brand i i can't tell you how on brand
that is that's amazing kevin clark of
the ringer here on the rich eisen show
so did you get any sense when you spoke
to mahomes uh and were around the chiefs
at all this summer
that there was a hangover coming
potentially because that's
that's what this one looks like to me
man i mean a a team that's been in the
super bowl
twice and has had you know and then then
lost and
and it's you know playing long seasons
two years in a row and tyree killed
dropping balls and the injuries hitting
and then the turnovers come
that reeks of super bowl hangover what
was your
general sense of things that could have
maybe even
given a
window into the two and three chief
start we're now seeing kevin i thought
they were trying to
avoid a hangover by being proactive it
was really interesting because when i
spent time with mahomes in august it
wasn't that much time but you know he
had said he watched the super bowl
basically to learn what he did wrong
even though i think the entire world
including us thinks he did almost
nothing wrong in that game he just got
battered by a bad offensive line an
incredibly fast defense in tampa bay um
but he was watching it to sort of learn
okay he thought he was bailing from a
clean pocket too often he made some
mistakes he he thought once he got hit
he started going uh through his reads
left and left and not making the right
play
right now with the chiefs this is a
defensive problem josh allen last night
on on passes over 20 yards was five of
six for 213 yards no interceptions
perfect passer rating um this is a
disaster right now for the kansas city
chiefs and their defense
i don't know how you fix it uh there's
no you know people were asking me last
time on twitter is there a move they can
make well you know
shut down corners or top safeties you
know they're somebody to replace daniel
sorens and those guys are not exactly on
the open market in october so it's going
to be tough for them um but this was bad
i mean chris jones and we talked about
it all the time daniel jeremiah calls it
jenga pieces where you remove a guy and
you find out very quickly how important
he is chris jones is obviously
we knew he was great but to see the lack
of pass rush last night when chris jones
was out was actually quite startling um
and then beyond that they just couldn't
get get anything going um this was bad
and and i don't know
how you fix it in the sense that i don't
know how you get back to being one of
the afc's top teams when this conference
is really really good the bills are
great um the chargers look awesome um
the bills by the way i mean they game
planned they changed their whole
personnel for this i was with brandon
bean and sean mcdermott in uh in august
as well and they said bean told me that
one of the reasons they took two pass
rushers with their first two picks in
the draft was because they watched the
tape of kansas city and they wanted to
gear themselves towards that afc
championship game and and and where they
came up short and try to get over that
hump they put a target on the chiefs and
the fact that they won this game in such
a resounding fashion has to be a massive
massive emotional left i know everybody
says oh you want to win every game
whatever like they they really
the amount of time in buffalo i heard
people talk about the chiefs uh told me
that they they built their season around
this kind of thing well i mean
it's remarkable kevin that the bills
have achieved a certain level of of just
needing to fine-tune their roster in the
offseason with a specific target in mind
the only one that could prevent them
from getting to where they want to go
it's interesting you mentioned the
chargers because defensively i'm
concerned about them
as well you know um and the browns just
put 42 on them yeah you know um
the derrick carr
put um put put a third quarter on them
in in on the monday night or that almost
cost him the game
they do have a tremendous quarterback
who do you think could be the team
that what about the ravens who we see
tonight i mean what what team do you
think would prevent the bills because it
sure is not coming from within the house
in the afc east that's for sure
you know i'm ready to rule out the afc
east um outside of buffalo but no it's
funny it would be a kind of a great
irony if if the bill spent all of his
time trying to beat the chiefs in the
playoffs and they don't even face them
in the playoffs right um so
i think that that's the tier right now
i'd go bills number one
i would say the charges right behind
that right now maybe that's recency bias
they probably should have lost yesterday
but they they won and i think that you
know i saw that stat and if you saw it
the browns are the first team in history
to score 40 points not turn the ball
over and lose before this teams were
463-0 in those situations okay um the
browns played a perfect game uh they
just made a couple mistakes baker ran a
really bad two minutes there was a very
very very fishy uh defensive passenger
appearance call one point um but
winning games you should lose is the
hallmark of a good team and a special
team i love brandon staley i love justin
herbert i love that roster i think the
defense has problems but so does almost
every defense in the nfl right now so i
put the charges right beyond that and
then i would put the ravens on that tier
two i really want to see what they look
like tonight um but i'm i'm extremely
willing to be talked into to the ravens
as an afc contender but right now it's
buffalo with everybody else so then uh
break down the nfc for me in your
estimation because that nfc has already
put the bed five weeks in
what do you think yeah um i i think that
it's interesting because i think that
what we saw from the bucks last year
tells me that i want to hold off on any
judgments on them and it's interesting
because there's just uh
there's just a
threshold with the cornerbacks where it
becomes too much to win a super bowl if
you don't have them but i don't know
what that is it's almost like what we
saw with the chiefs in the office of
line play last year right where was we
didn't understand how bad it was going
to be until we saw in the field one day
and said oh wow they don't have a they
don't have an offensive line they
protect patrick from homes anymore and
it's the biggest game of the year um and
so i'm waiting to see on the health of
their defense i don't think richard
sherman is going to be a high level guy
um if they have to actually depend on
him to make huge plays if he's just a
depth guy and yet you put him in certain
spots i'm fine with that that's a
low-risk maneuver but if he's what
you're depending on that's a different
equation for me right now
it's the cowboys and this is a tier so
i'm not ranking these teams but i'm
saying cowboys cardinals rams
packers bucks and
i depending on the day i i move that
around but you know on our podcast
offensive ringer nfl show i i wouldn't
be surprised if the cowboys won the nfc
you know what you said that to us in the
sun you know in in the summer and i saw
you retweeted my soliloquy from a couple
weeks ago saying it's time for me to
give the cowboys what they you know i'm
not one of those members of the media
that won't give them their due and they
deserve it and you said hey i told you
they were surprise team in the summer i
saw that tweet
kevin i saw it i'm just i'm just
reminding the people what's funny about
it rich is that i didn't even i talked
them up on radio shows on my podcast on
video whatever cost them up for eight
months and then the week it came time to
actually have nfl predictions on our
site with the week the dak was out and
the jerry jones was calling the texas
rangers about back shoulder and i was
like this all seems a little weird so i
didn't even pick them to win the
division i spent eight months talking
about this and then like the next week i
was like oh no they look amazing
so i talked myself out of my own pick
that i spent eight months trying to
convince other people of oh kevin
come on i feel for you brother because i
you know i thought washington football
team is going to do it too the eagles
just had a nice win but i i the cowboys
are clearly the class of the of the nfc
uh thanks for the call kevin i'm glad uh
i always
loved picking your brain and certainly i
know you're a boxing guy too to have you
on a special day like today after fury
and wilder and then on top of it you
know i saw your twitter feed earlier
this morning at least saving you from uh
this concept of uh your tweet what's the
best college football scheme podcast and
i'm trying to learn kevin kevin kevin
you need a hobby break out of it i say
this on behalf of your wife who i've
never met come on now come on come on
she's lost i will say this it's because
the university of miami is probably
going to fire their coach at some point
this year hopefully and i just want to
get an understanding what's going on at
that level um so there's a reason for it
but on the other hand it's a deeply
pathetic tweet i'm sorry no i just want
to just i'm trying to help you you know
what i mean i'm trying to help you you
know just watch ted lasso if you already
haven't
take care of yourself kevin okay
all right kevin clark everybody from the
ringer at by kevin clark
what's the best
college football scheme podcast i mean
good good that is so deep oh my gosh
it's not even playable that's how deep
it is it's not playable i mean i like
sports i don't think i like yeah that
much
he's got a wife he's got a life
he just moved he moved back to the east
coast okay very good he's got a life
very good
so
how about this let's just
linger on this for a second
where do you want to be in the nfl
here's where you want hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here